Look we've all been there right
letting our fear and anger get the
best of us intentionally expanding the
borders of the false world we created
mom are you coming down soon
mom our game is freaking out
is she asleep mommy's not sleeping
honey she's just resting her eyes
mom my head feels weird it's like really
noisy i don't like it resting her eyes
as punishment for my reckless evening I plan on
taking a quarantine style staycation a whole day
just to myself that'll show me
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
new Wandavision nightmare video i was already
making this new video then marvel dropped a new
trailer for Wandavision episode 7 that has another
big nightmare easter egg in it that just helps
prove the point that i was trying to make so i'll
explain what's going on during this and what's
going on with nightmare and all the easter eggs
for him during the series so far if you're new
to my channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos i will be doing episodes for all the series
that are happening this year including falcon
and winter soldier the loki series there's even
more stuff coming up later this year too careful
for spoilers for everything that's happened on
Wandavision so far but in this trailer obviously
they're doing a modern family parody for episode
7 because they move to the next decade of sitcoms
in the 2010s she's referencing the events of her
expanding the hex but also trying to discipline
herself but not discipline herself at the same
time she's sort of running away from the problem
not completely dealing with it i'm going to give
myself a quarantine style staycation that'll teach
me i'll talk about billy and tommy during my full
episode 7 video which will be posting next after
this video because they also say that their heads
are hurting that's important for what's happening
later in the series that's all building up to
the big moments of the finale but it's tied to
what's happening with nightmare in the background
and the hex in general the other nightmare easter
eggs that you notice though when she's lying in
her bed obviously there's the hexagon patterns
that you see popping up all over the series the
shape of the hex itself is a hexagon but when she
lies her head back on her own pillow you notice
the shape is two eyes to green eyes staring down
on her like someone is watching her they also
had a version of this in a poster for the series
a long time ago before episode one dropped like
you notice in the wallpaper in the background here
there's this green looking devil face and a lot
of people thought it was mephisto but i actually
thought because it was green it was meant to be
nightmare because nightmare's color scheme is
green so the number of other easter eggs for him
on the show we know Wandavision is crossing over
with doctor strange two multiverse of madness
so when they first announced the Wandavision
series a lot of us assumed we would see teasers
for the doctor strange two villain during the
episodes at some point we just didn't know how
big those would be or what form they would take
and way back after the first doctor strange movie
came out the director at the time scott derrickson
talked about how nightmare was marvel's planned
villain for the sequel and we actually found out
about nightmare way before we ever found out
about the Wandavision series so because there
have been so many nightmare name drops the past
couple of episodes so many demonic references so
many darker supernatural things that seem like
they were at play in the Wandavision episodes
have been purposefully as confusing as possible
with the way they tell her story they really want
us to think that there is something larger at play
influencing what's happening with the hex and it's
not just some simple boss level power upgrade that
scarlet witch got as evan peters quicksilver said
during episode 6 this is a long way from giving
people nightmares and shooting red wiggly woos
out of your hands obviously also a reference to
nightmare but also a reference to her boss level
power upgrade the composer for doctor strange too
said that she has a lot of darkness in her and a
lot of the darkness in her comes from the terrible
things she's experienced all the trauma that she's
been repressing this whole time obviously until
we have our full house of m moment where she
explodes she goes full blown crazy there's even a
funny interview clip of elizabeth olsen basically
giving away the plot of Wandavision years before
she knew that it was going to be a series she said
oh marvel's never going to do this but i would
love to do this i mean my favorite is house of m
but that would never happen but um never say never
in this i mean if she could if she could have two
fake babies and everyone tell her that they don't
really exist and then her just go nuts that would
be unbelievable but i don't think they're gonna do
that it might be a little too dark for the marvel
universe when she loses her mind it's my favorite
thing in the comics make all the jokes you want
about her going full spoiler bros and giving away
the plot of Wandavision but to be true that was
actually long before they'd ever planned to do
the series so technically she's not spoiling it
she's just saying that that would be her favorite
story to do so we've just been watching her on
the episode so far dealing with her trauma in the
most unhealthy way possible mostly by ignoring it
and creating the hex to give herself this place
to live out a fantasy family life with vision
in the twins billy and tommy like the hydrosoap
commercial says go to a place where you can run
away from all your problems which is basically
what the hex is but the show has tried to present
the hex in the most mysterious and confusing way
as possible even if you've read the house of m's
storyline they're swerving on some of the comic
book explainers they're changing some of the comic
book plot so it's not simply her losing her mind
and unleashing her reality warping magic but there
are so many suspicious things that are happening
in so many characters people like agnes who i know
we all believe is agatha harkness who seem like
they know more is going on than they've let on
but are also really inconsistent in the way that
they act towards scarlet witch and vision like
sometimes agnes is really afraid of her sometimes
she's not so what has the show been hiding from us
is there some other bigger force that's at play
that influenced her in the creation of the hex
the way scarlet witch told evan peters quicksilver
she says she has no idea how the hex was created
she just felt this empty nothingness she felt
absolutely alone then suddenly the next thing
you know they're driving into the hex at the
beginning of episode 1. now we already know what
happened with vision's body they just explained
that she broke into sword then stolen then the
events of episode 1 pickup but there's still a
lot of unexplained time in what was happening
between the time where she grabs his body and
they drive in to what looks like a tv simulation
inside the hex it had only been about two weeks
since avengers end game ended when she went to
steel vision's body then what was happening in
that two week period so the whole thing with a
nightmare character in the comics is that he's
actually someone who influences from the shadows
not literally more metaphorically because he can
only feed off of people's dreams in their psychic
energy so he's not somebody who can walk around
on planet earth on a normal day there was a really
interesting line of dialogue when quicksilver was
talking to scarlet witch about what was going on
inside the hex with all the people like where all
the children come from where'd you get them from
then he proceeded to talk to her about it as
if he knew exactly what was going on like oh
all their personalities are there underneath the
surface families are together husbands are with
wives people have better jobs and he basically
said that the people that she doesn't need for
any given scenario in any given episode are
basically just kept in stasis in their homes
or in their beds asleep so there have been so many
nightmare name drops the past couple of episodes
and it seems like they're swerving on the straight
up mephisto explainer for everything and he feeds
on people's dreams when they're asleep or their
psychic energies it would make sense that the
hex is like this giant feeding trough for him to
come swim in like if you talk about the commercial
what if nightmare is the shark in scarlet witch
is the little boy and he really is feeding off
the psychic energy the shark even says i was
hungry too until i found yo magic as in your
magic then you also have the issue of a lot of
different characters on the show acting really
inconsistently particularly the agnes character so
a lot of people are now wondering if she's somehow
connected to nightmare if she's being influenced
by him or working with him because there are times
when she seems really afraid and genuine like
she does seem like a relatively nice person
then there are other times when she is the worst
nosy neighbor who wants to know everything about
scarlet witch and vision's business that she
can get her hands on she seemed fascinated by
the idea of scarlet witch bringing people back
from the dead but why did she avoid going in the
house when scarlet wish was giving birth to billy
and tommy that was one of the only times that she
didn't try to barge into the house and you would
think something that big she would try to go into
the house for also you may have noticed that she's
not always wearing her act at the harness pin from
the comics that's basically what that brooch
is supposed to be the first couple of episodes
that's why they wanted you to look at it and say
oh that's probably agatha harkness because she's
wearing her pin just like in the comics and she's
dressed like a witch in the halloween episode
just like agatha harness was a witch usually the
connection between agatha harkness and scarlet
witch in the comics is she's been something of a
mentor to her helps her learn more powerful magic
or helps her with really supernatural problems or
she's even a nanny to some other characters like
agatha the harkness was the nanny of franklin
richards if we're talking about big fantastic
four connections so if agnes really is act of the
harkness and she is a sorceress just like doctor
strange as a sorcerer she'd be powerful enough to
counteract some of the effects of the hex and it
would explain why she's able to speak and actually
have some sort of movement while all these other
people on the periphery are just stuck stationary
dead in their tracks there are theories that maybe
she was posing as a therapist to scarlet witch
at some point after avengers end game during
that two-week period before she went to steel
vision's body and maybe in working with nightmare
she was one of the people that pushed scarlet
witch to go steel vision's body and gave her the
idea for creating the hex but here's the thing
with her acting very inconsistently the whole
idea that nightmare might actually be possessing
different characters on the show because for a
long time people were wondering if evan peters
was going to be playing a version of nightmare
or mephisto on the tv show he certainly acted in
a very suspicious way and when he got knocked over
the tombstones one of the tombstones even read not
on her side as if to give a clue to the fact that
this character who was posing as her brother
did not have her best interest at heart
so the new theory on the show is that nightmare
may be possessing different people's bodies
hopping around like going into agatha harkness's
body and what he's really trying to do is push
scarlet witch over the edge to purposefully
expand the hex to encompass the entire earth
because while he can't cross over into earth's
dimension because that would alert someone
like doctor strange or he just doesn't have the
power to do that like he doesn't in the comics
so i know we're all wondering if she's going to be
creating more x-men mutant characters in the mcu
because of the way they explain how the barrier
the reality warping magic changes people's dna
mutates it but also the other threat would be
that she covers the entire planet with the hex
that would give nightmare access to the entire
planet of people and if he really is going to
wind up being the main villain of doctor strange
too then obviously they wouldn't defeat him during
Wandavision and we're all expecting a benedict
cumberbatch doctor strange crossover by the finale
when scarlet witch really goes over the
edge but again the whole idea here is that
it's wanda that's doing all these things but
she's being pushed over the edge she's being
antagonized for the purposes of expanding the
hex so that nightmare can eventually cross over
into our dimension fully so everyone just post
all your theories in the comments below how do
you think that nightmare is tied up in all this
what do you think the true purpose of the hex is
because obviously there's something darker at
play than her just creating a bunch of mutants
and living out a fantasy life with vision
in the children my full Wandavision episode
7 video is gonna post on friday just like normal
everyone click here for that Wandavision avengers
end game deleted scene that explains what happens
right before she steals vision's body and how she
comes to the hex in episode one and then click
here for my full Wandavision episode 6 video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!